au coeur de la verdoyante vallée de la
loue une usine d'emballage alimentaire
qui se veut verte elle aussi ici les
employés fournissent eux-mêmes une
partie de la matière première à nice a
apporté des déchets plastiques depuis
chez elle
je les ai mis dans ce nouveau bac que
l'entreprise a mis à disposition et
c'est super pratique et on a
l'impression de faire partie comme ça
d'un mouvement pour pour pour ça et
mieux pour notre planète
un mouvement lancé il ya plus de 15 ans
dans cette entreprise
en plus du bac de tri des machines comme
celles ci sont conçus grâce à elle les
chutes de plastique issu de la
fabrication ne se perdent pas mais se
transforme de ce site ne sort aucun kilo
de matière tous les rebuts que dans
d'autres industries ont achetés dans des
bennes à déchets et puis qu'on va
enfouir ou combat qu'on va vendre à des
sociétés
nous on les réutilise on les broie et on
les réintroduit dans des silos qui sont
à l'entrée des usines pour les
réutiliser dans nos processus de
production 1,7 milliard de produits sont
fabriqués chaque année par le groupe
présent dans toute l'europe
les emballages sont le résultat d'un
mélange de plastique pe t9 et recyclés
en moyenne une barquette est constituée
à 70 % de matière au générés ici on a
quatre échantillons de matières
premières donc on a la matière vierge
on a leur broyer interne issus de nos
chutes technique et puis on a la matière
recyclée qu'on achète à l'extérieur qui
est issu du tri sélectif et notre
problématique aujourd'hui c'est de
trouver cette matière puisque
l'extension des consignes de tri en
france n'est pas suffisamment développée
et donc le groupe travaille en étroite
collaboration avec les pouvoirs publics
pour ce recyclage des poubelles jaunes à
100% sur tous les emballages la
simplification du tri devrait concerner
tous les français d'ici 2022
de quoi alimenter la boucle infinie du
recyclage